hi  i wanted to see if you happen to know  anyone okay something really crazy  happened after this and i realized i  never gave you guys an update on so if  you saw this video months ago you'll  know i went door-to-door in nice  neighborhoods asking if they knew  anybody that was hiring i decided to do  it for one day i just wanted to see what  would happen one of the doors that i  knocked on was the ceo of a company he  ended up giving his main recruiter my  information and they actually wanted to  interview me for a job i ended up  turning it down because i changed my  mind i decided i really wanted to try  working for myself right now but what i  learned is to put yourself out there  because you never know what's going to  happen